What are your thoughts on the use of black salve for skin cancers?
Well, I'm a huge fan of black salve for skin cancers. My wife used black salve
her melanoma
two spots of melanoma
10 years ago, and
I'm convinced if she did not use black salve on her melanoma and ended up doing what's called a mose
surgery, which a dermatologist would do for a skin cancer.
She would have probably little use of
you know her
right arm from her shoulder because it was up on her right shoulder
and the size of the tumor that came out after using black salve was quite large,
but that she also had it on her left
forearm at the brachial radialis muscle area and the size of that was quite large.
So to do mose surgery, they go in and they remove as much cancer as they can visually see
sent it to the lab. See if they have a clean mortar. It has to be over two millimeters. It's
three millimeter clean mortar. If not, they have to go remove more, go more. Well, if she would add
part of her brachial radialis removed and
her left arm probably would have damaged the brachial plexus
in the right shoulder. So she could have limited motion. Black salve spares all healthy tissues
and black salve will kill cancer cells and draw that out. Now, you don't want to do that
and hazardly, you have to be very careful with that. We don't sell black salve in our store any longer,
but just because of safety reasons and FDA regulations that we do have black salve protocol
that we can send people, but we have to be really careful with it because it's highly regulated
and you just got to be careful doing it does cause a lot of pain.